Hello world.
It's the Raj and I'm going to show you
how I read research papers and give you
some additional tips on how you
can consume them more efficiently.
Reading research papers is an art,
whether the topic is machine
learning or cryptography,
distributed consensus or networking.
In order to truly have an educated
opinion on a particular topic in computer
science,
you've got to get yourself acquainted
with current research in that subfield.
It's easy to agree with the claim
if it's got enough hype behind it,
but being critical and balanced in
your assessment is a skill that can be
learned. Phd Students are taught
how to do this in Grad school,
but you too can learn how to do this.
It just takes patience
and practice and coffee.
Lots of coffee every single week.
I read between 10 to 20 research papers
in order to keep up with the field and
I've gotten better at it over time
and I don't have any graduate degrees.
I'm just the guy who really loves this
stuff and I teach myself everything using
our new collective university,
the Internet.
One of my favorite resources to find
papers on machine learning is the machine
learning subreddit.
People post papers they find interesting
every day and they've also got this
cool weekly.
What are you reading thread where people
post the papers that interest them the
most currently.
Additionally there is this web app called
Archive sanity.com created by Andre
carpathy which basically goes through
archive and finds the papers that are most
relevant. You can filter them
by what interests you buy,
which ones are most popular or by
the ones that are most cited lately.
Google and deep mind respectively
published their work on their websites for
easy access and there are
of course journals like
nature that you can find some
top papers in easily.
The pace of research is accelerating
and machine learning because of a few
reasons not including Schmidt, Huber
in academia and in the public sphere.
The democratization of data computing,
power,
education and algorithms is all
steadily happening over the Internet.
Because of this, more people are able to
make their own insights into this field.
In the industry.
The big tech companies profit more when
their own teams discover new machine
learning methods.
So there's this race to create faster,
more intelligent algorithms.
All that is to say that there are a lot
of papers you could be reading right now,
so how are you supposed to
know what to read? Well,
what I've found is that every week there
are maybe two or three papers that are
getting the most attention in machine
learning and the tools I've mentioned help
me find them and read them,
but most of my reading is a
result of me having a goal.
That goal could be to learn more
about activation functions or perhaps
probabilistic models that
use attention mechanisms.
Once I've got that goal,
it makes it much easier create a reading
strategy that points towards that goal.
Just being a good math heavy machine
learning paper reader is not a goal to
aspire to. Your stamina is more
of a function of human motivation,
which is a function of the goals
you're trying to accomplish.
I found that I can crush through and
understand the most difficult papers much
more when I have a real reason to do so.
So let's take the landmark
paper by a friend of mine,
Ian Goodfellow on generative
adversarial networks as an example.
There is a lot in this paper.
He synthesizes some ideas here that made
young Macoun say that this concept was
the coolest idea in deep
learning in the last 10 years.
The way I read papers is by performing
a three pass approach on the first pass.
I'll just skim through the
paper to get a gist of it,
meaning I'll first read the title if the
title sounds interesting and relevant,
generative adversarial networks. Yo,
let's go. I'll read the abstract,
the abstract acts as a short standalone
summary of the work of the paper that
people can use as an overview.
If the abstract is compelling,
an adversarial process between two
neural networks that resembles a game.
All right, this is lit. Then I'll
skim through the rest of the paper.
By that I mean I'll carefully
read the introduction,
then read the section and subsection
headings, but ignore everything else.
Mainly ignore the math.
I never read the math on the first pass.
Are we the conclusion at the end and
maybe glance over the references mentally
ticking off the ones I've already read.
If there are any,
I just assumed the math is
correct on the first pass.
My goal for this first pass is to just
be able to understand the aims of the
author. What are the paper's
main contributions here?
What problems as the attempt to solve?
Is this a paper I'm actually
interested in reading more of.
Once I've done the first pass,
I'll go back to see what other people are
saying about this paper and compare my
initial observations to.
There's basically the aim of this first
pass is to ensure that it's worth my
time to continue analyzing this paper.
Life is short and there are
too many things to read. If
it does peak my interest,
then I'll reread it a second
time on the second pass.
I'll read it again this time
more critically and I'll
also take notes as I go.
I'll actually read all the English
text and I'll try to get a high level
understanding of the math
that's happening in the paper,
so it's a mini Max game that looks
to optimize a nash equilibrium. Okay.
I kind of get that.
Eventually the generator network creates
fake samples that are indistinguishable
from the real thing, so the
discriminator is powerless. Cool.
I'll read the finger descriptions.
Any plots and graphs that are available
and try to understand the algorithm at a
high level.
A lot of times the author will break
down an equation by factoring it out.
I avoid to analyze this
on the second pass,
I see that it's using a loss function
called the colback Leibler divergence.
Never heard of that one, but I do get the
concept of minimizing a loss function.
When I read the experiments,
I'll try to evaluate the results.
Are they repeatable? Are the
findings well supported by evidence.
Once I'd done that,
hopefully there is some associated code
with the repository available on get
hub. I'll download the code
and start reading it myself.
I'll try to compile and run the code
locally to replicate the results as well.
Usually comments in the code
help further my understanding.
I'll also look for any
additional resources on the
web that help further explain
the text articles, summaries, tutorials.
Usually a popular paper
will have a breakdown that
someone else has done online
that will help drive the key points
home for me. After this second pass,
I'll have a Jupiter notebook full of
notes and associated helper images.
Since I teach this stuff on youtube,
teaching is really the best way
to fully understand any topic.
When it comes to the third pass,
it's all about the math.
My focus on the third pass is to really
understand every detail of the mass.
I might just use a pen and paper and
break down the equations in the paper
myself.
I'll use Wikipedia to help me understand
any of the more formal math concepts
fully like the Kale divergence and
if I'm feeling really ambitious,
I'll try to replicate the paper
programmatically using the hyper parameter
settings and equations that it describes.
After all of this I'll feel confident
enough to discuss it with other people.
Reading papers is not easy and nobody can
read long manipulations of complicated
equations fast.
The key is to never give up.
Turn your frustrations into fuel to get
better. You will understand this paper.
You will master this subject.
You will become awesome at this.
It gets easier every time as you
build your Merkel Dag of knowledge.
See what I did there. If you don't get a
math concept, guess what? Khan Academy.
We'll teach you anything you
need to know for free and lastly,
do not hesitate to ask for help.
There are study groups and communities
online that are centered around the
latest research in machine learning
that you can post your questions too.
Don't be afraid to reach
out to researchers as well.
You're actually doing them a favor by
having them explain to you in terms you
understand.
All scientists need more experience
translating complex topics.
I've got lots of great links for you
in the description and I hope you found
this video useful. If you want to
learn more about machine learning,
AI and blockchain technology,
hit the subscribe button,
and for now I've got to reread the capital
network paper, so thanks for watching.